these workers say they haven't been paid
in two years they Supply food to public
schools in Ghana now desperate suppliers
are demanding what's owed to them with
interest because of inflation we just
are asking that the due process should
be followed and our money should be
given to us are we asking for too much
Ghana has signed a new three-year
bailout program with the international
monetary fund to bring down inflation
and fix its economic problems
but this may not reduce poverty levels
create jobs or increase salaries loads
of new taxes have been introduced
so the taxes are going to start biting
the end all together as this Coalition I
think we should start preparing for some
unrest on the labor front it's very
possible as they start to realize that
there are earnings
have
halved in purchasing power
of these loans meaning the government
has to cut spending and that the price
of water fuel and electricity will
likely keep going up it will reduce our
profits and it will also lead to
increases in prices because we have to
pass it on to Consumers and when it goes
like that we cannot do more so when we
can't do more it means that we cannot
retain more staff we have to lay up some
of the stuff
the government says a three billion
dollar IMF bailout will help pay for
imports get the cost of living crisis
under control and finish development
projects
out of large projects like this
unfinished Road had stalled because
there was no money to finish them the
critics of the government say corruption
and mismanagement are also to blame for
Gardner's economic difficulties
ghanaians have experience with bailouts
it's the country's 17th IMF program
since it gained independence in 1957.
the question is will this loan lead to
economic Prosperity or just more
hardship for its people haramutasa Al
Jazeera Accra